[Musique]
politique dans trois jours le week-end
prochain les socialistes eux tiendront
leur comité directeur pour l'instant on
le sait le parti socialiste a déjà deux
candidats à la candidature pour les
présidentielles michel rocard et jean
pierre chevènement un double choix qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité chez les
militants socialistes alors pour mettre
tout le monde d'accord plusieurs
responsables fédéraux du parti
socialiste ont écrit aujourd'hui à
françois mitterrand ils se disent prêts
à créer les conditions de sa candidature
à la tête de ce mouvement le sénateur de
l'essonne jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon 36 ans le plus jeune sénateur
de france dirigeants des socialistes de
l'essonne très lié aux animateurs du
mouvement de la jeunesse de décembre 86
notamment isabelle thomas avec qui il a
signé une contribution lors du dernier
congrès il entend incarner la nouvelle
génération du ps résolument à gauche est
décidé à imposer une nouvelle
candidature mitterrand il faut arrêter
cette espèce de danse autour du totem
françois mitterrand en voulez-vous être
candidat françois mitterrand soyez
candidat je crois que ça c'est une
conception de la politique qui est
complètement archaïque on attend que un
personnage se déclare je crois que
sa candidature est tellement importante
pour se payer pour la gauche qu'il faut
en créer les conditions et c'est ça que
nous essayons de faire il faut donc ils
participaient complètement je vis pas
d'attendre que françois mitterrand
disent oui ou non françois mitterrand il
a apporté la preuve notamment pendant
les événements de novembre et décembre
dernier qu'il avait cette capacité
d'écouté
d'attention à ce qui est nouveau dans la
société française à ce qui bouge lui il
a besoin de se mettre en route man sur
la tête pour avoir l'air jeune
d'ailleurs il essaye pas de quoi quand
on regarde par exemple ce que disent les
jeunes autour de nous ce que disent les
sondages il ya une confiance il ya une
sympathie à l'égard de françois
mitterrand qui est très fort très
profonde c'est pas pour rien qu'on
l'appelle tentant
[Musique]